[Music]
in don't be cheeky news submitted 2x2
submitted by to invade me on about butts
please be about butts oh it is an
Australian theme park got accused of
sexism after banning cheeky bikini
bottoms I mean cuz everyone's wearing
thongs now why I know they really are I
got a nice bonus when we were in Hawaii
oh no I cut myself at the pool area in
our hotel throws this Australian family
and both kids were just butt naked Wow
Kyle Owens the girl are we so afraid of
nudity I thought it was cool wait he had
his dangler out his danglers I yeah yeah
I thought it was killing like three or
four and they're just playing around I
thought it was cool I'm like what's
wrong with that I don't like this I
think we should be able show as much of
our but as we can normalize it
but sir everyone's got a butt but Sarge
should not be that sexual it's like
you're right hope comes out of it yeah
so like it's my buns you're gonna have
to but guys will make everything sexual
right like a [ __ ] fireEye's wall
there's caca coming out they'll probably
still jerk off to that I mean two girls
one cup that should tell you everything
right yeah this this place called guys
will pay to get crapped on yeah Donald
Trump oh really
I'll peed oh that's a little different
does it you'll need this lip only this
little chick this much room difference
disgusting yeah so this place called
adventure world in Perth Australia they
posted on Facebook this image oh well
they posted an image in the caption it
adventure world is a family-friendly
park please choose appropriate swimwear
when visiting their zombie cheeky and it
says don't do these do these nutty dumb
is not like the one on the bottom right
how is that more cheating these are good
these are hot to me I let the top one's
the best right there's no difference
you're offended by the upper buttocks
just this upward chic the upper lower
cheek totally fine but upper cheek oh
that's naughty
I don't know all four of them all four
of them make me horny so clearly that
they have a problem I think it's the
crab they can't avoid it but you beat
two cracky but to me like when I put on
that bottom left one it ends up being
like the top left one yeah some people
just have bigger but that's not fair
it's not our fault that they don't make
I told the bigger the but the smaller
the bikini is that the rule I have been
by a completely different size for the
bottom just to make just to try to cover
it make you buys the bottom right why a
large bottom and a small top but also I
guess their whole thing if they're
saying it's a family-friendly thing so
they're worried about little kids seeing
butt skin but little kids are naked
anyway register it as sexual though
they're not even look they don't even
care funny it's like I saw but what I'm
changing your front of tight guy he goes
yo PPE oh and I'm like stop making me
uncomfortable he says you have a dick
no like he knows that that's where like
pee comes from oh I thought you were
saying peepee thinking I'm a dick I was
like wow me in the peepee oh yeah so
there a lot of comments about this and
one said and this is why sexism still
exists and then no one says those men
better cover their nipples too won't
somebody think of the children
that used to be alone another one says
here in America a bathing suit this
offender huh you see guys with no nipple
showing in 1920s we're going backwards
yeah so then another one said bum cheeks
will scar your kids stupidest thing I've
ever seen but oh and then uh but no no
and says thanks for policing women's
bodies adventure worlds now where's the
men's version
true and then
meant a lot of wear Speedos right right
you can see more than that yeah I got
nightmares about ball theme that I'm
like you're coming out of the same I
think I think guys is the opposite you
want to cover them up as much as you can
yeah well tell them to tell that to the
[ __ ] speed a warning guys they're
happy they're weird what if a bunch of
guys come in with a Borat bikini you
know what I would do I would come in
with their like the full bottoms and
then just like nipple covers okay say
anything about that yeah yeah so other
people said glad to see something still
glad to see something still standing for
modesty and appropriateness Oh guys soon
I support this adventure world official
page people have no manners these days
cover up and have some respect for
yourselves and consideration for the
other people who are also enjoying the
park another one says well done
adventure world I think this is a great
move these are all religious old people
right it's like projection because they
feel shame and guilt for their own
bodies and stuff
these old fat ladies can't wear that
phone and they think that your body
should be preserved for God and your
husband because secretly they fantasize
about being gangbangs I don't know I
like this whole like I have the right to
hootchie movement because I'm just
sitting here like enjoying the view
that's the thing is it's a personal
choice like I know as a woman I don't of
you guys do too but like I know when I
wear stuff like that that like
unfortunately I have to deal with what
comes with that yeah or just like the
gawking or like the automatic yeah
that's what I don't understand is when a
girl is wearing like a straight you know
tooth floss and she's like oh my god
stop staring yeah it's like but
shouldn't we be comfortable in our
bodies and feel like we can show it off
without the fear of a guy jerking off in
the corner I'll answer that but first
they have to subscribe because I want to
make sure that they stay tuned for this
answer and if they don't subscribe then
I'm not gonna tell them um I tell you
what you know what turns me on
[ __ ] ABS and like that V when I see
that on a guy I'm like a lot of ladies
like maybe showing that [ __ ] all the
time
I Adventure Park world
in a mission too horny yeah and it's
like what a butts on my thing you know I
like a really funny dark humor and
sarcastic guy and in comedy clubs
they're showing that off all the time
and it's like I am married stop in it
Wow oh yeah that's interesting yeah so
adventure world had a statement and said
let's talk to let's not confuse the
issue this update is about dress
standards and dress standards only it is
not gender specific the world is a
family-friendly theme park we keep
informed of industry trends and whilst
this was not a decision taken lightly it
is in line with other parks nationwide
what guy is wearing a [ __ ]
thong mm-hmm
European guys yeah I don't even know
that Australia made swimsuits like the
ones at the bottom right looks like all
the like surf capitals of the world like
Hawaii Australia they all their bikinis
that you probably invented that I've
been like five-year-olds their butt
cheeks are just popping up that's just
the style Europeans make it I'm all
right your pins I mean I think it's like
when you watch what do you call it like
those National Geographic documentaries
like T's are all over the place but it's
not sexualized because it's just normal
and guess what that could be like a
conversation started with your kid at
that age to talk about not sexualizing
women that's exactly what I was thinking
it's like oh I see her but I'd be like
yeah and that's her but she can do
whatever she wants that you'll nitwit
have a conversation with your child so
I'm not having guess I don't know if a
conversation can prevent kids from being
horny though but how they react what we
say Society projects us what makes kids
horny should start to change right like
the reason why pubic hair why well why
women started shaving all their pubic
hair off is because porns showed women
bare skin and they thought that's what
was sexy when in reality the only reason
why women important started waxing all
their [ __ ] hair off was because it was
better visually for the camera you could
see more you could see more push more
stimulating enticing so why don't we t
why don't we start teaching people to
not imagine but says the thing that
gives you a rock-hard Boehner and I
understand you've already been
programmed that way
but what if we teach the kids like your
sign to jerk off the [ __ ] takoyaki
balls I don't know girls personality
traits get turned on by dopes
personality though I went takoyaki balls
you went personality I'm a very noble I
think but I liked things before I saw
porn as you don't know what you're
conditioned mind you exactly because
imagine if you grew up in those in those
tribes were all the women are Ari Bob
Wilson yeah like the balls in the lip
and that's a war near the feet binding
and that makes them whole and the foot
touches the woman there is something
like evolutionarily that men see
curvaceous women is more attractive
because I have childbearing right true
it's a ratio there's a scientific ratio
of women 6 24 36 that it could be only
if she's 3 oh I was quoting oh thanks
forgot you're young yeah it's baby got
back oh I know yeah I mean oh yeah I
think sexuality is cultural and like
it's you can there's a balance between
the two but also I think it's biological
to where man just are attracted without
any you know pre like understanding of
what it's supposed to be just I remember
as a kid staring out women like grown
women like I don't know why I don't know
what's going on but I just couldn't stop
staring at them it's cuz you were
breastfed well women are beautiful yeah
and it's it is I'm staring at women yes
I was sexually attracted to them but I
was like I want a beer she's so pretty
my second grade teacher mr. Pendergrass
I was like character so pretty but
there's also a difference between seeing
your neighbors Ferrari and going I'm
gonna steal that [ __ ] yeah so I think
like and I think guys I mean the sec i
think the way that we're like looking at
sex is different to the way that guys
and girls develop separately because
just the experience like is completely
it just sounds different like this stuff
like when we see women as kids like you
can tell that there's someone that's
like super duper hot and she's like not
even the same age but you're like
reverse mullet
like you're like jailbait right you're
just like oh my god it's the mrs.
Robinson it's Stacy's mom it's like yeah
the mill it's like you don't even know
what to do with her but you're just like
what the [ __ ] it's crazy so wish
fulfillment thing to like you are young
and you hope to one day have that and if
you can somehow get it before you're
supposed to have it you're the [ __ ]
man yeah and I wouldn't know what to do
I'm like what am I gonna do just fill up
her boobies for like two hours and [ __ ]
like I don't know what to do
never even saw porn before yeah
[Music]
[Music]